in colonial America doctoring was a
profession that physicians and patients
today would find close to unrecognizable
medicine or physic as it was called was
based on ancient concepts of health and
illness physicians commonly treated
patients by bleeding them or inducing
vomiting what surgery there was took
place without anesthesia a doctor's bag
at the time of the Revolutionary War
contained only a few rudimentary
medications that's all there were
foxglove known today for its essential
ingredient digitalis to steady an ailing
heart opium to relieve pain ginger to
aid the digestion even the notion of
infection was absent from medicine since
the knowledge that germs cause disease
would not be advanced until more than a
century after the Declaration of
Independence a doctor's work was more
art than science and in most cases not
very good art at that
medicine has progressed more in the last
200 years indeed in the last 50 years
than in all previous human existence and
Yale University home to one of America's
earliest medical schools has played a
vital role in that progress
Yale College was established in 1701 in
Saybrook Connecticut and soon moved to
its permanent location in the small
coastal city of New Haven 80 miles
northeast of New York City in 1810 Yale
College and the Connecticut Medical
Society joined forces to create the
sixth Medical School in the United
States it opened three years later with
a faculty of five today Yale is one of
the world's leading academic medical
centers it ranks first among medical
schools and per capita funding from the
National Institutes of Health more than
1,200 full-time professors teach conduct
research and care for patients from the
region and from around the world
the Yale system of medical education
with its emphasis on student research
and collaborative learning has produced
leaders in every field of science and
medicine
in colonial America most people receive
their medical care in the home they
often turn to ministers for healing 18th
century doctoring being primarily rooted
in faith early American settlers saw
direct ties between their physical
health or lack thereof and their
spiritual well-being the average life
expectancy was only 35 years of age in
large part because as many as 30% of
infants and young children succumb to
illness anyone during this time could
call himself a doctor since there were
no licensing requirements physicians
were essentially artisans many of them
had not finished the equivalent of high
school they became physicians by
apprentices themselves to a local
physician by 1807 there were five
medical schools all along the eastern
seaboard they were all established in
connection with Eastern colleges in
Connecticut VL college and the state
medical society asked for permission to
form the first Medical School in
Connecticut it would remain the first
medical school for the next 150 years in
that state with its new faculty
including Nathan Smith and Benjamin
Silliman Yale's medical school
officially opened its doors in 1813 to
37 students some of the faculty earned
their living from the sale of lecture
tickets paid admission to their classes
rather than from salaries and tuition
similar to most medical schools at the
time the primary admission requirement
was good character in the beginning in
order to obtain the MD degree students
attended lectures for six months and
also spent time as apprentices to
practicing physicians in 1833 New Haven
became home to the nation's fourth
voluntary Hospital following the much
larger cities of Philadelphia New York
and Boston but hospitals were very
different institutions than they are
today
the hospital was not that terribly
central place for the care of most
Americans the hospital from most of that
period was a train it was a place for
the sick poor not so much for the
education of students the middle of the
19th century was a low point for the
medical profession in the United States
the proliferation of for-profit medical
schools often characterized by low
educational standards and ethics greatly
increased the production of poorly
trained practitioners leading to a
surplus of doctors and divisive
competition for students in many states
enrollments at established medical
school shrank the quality of applicants
decreased and efforts by the better
schools to improve the curriculum in
order to attract more qualified students
increased costs Yale was no stranger to
these challenges
there were plaintiff pleas to the Yale
corporation saying that that we
desperately need money and it was really
the review with Flexner that sort of
made people who read look at the school
and what they had Abraham Flexner was a
respected educator whose assessment of
the overall quality of medical schools
and frank-- recommendations for
improvement would influence American
medicine for the next 100 years he
visited each of the 155 medical schools
then operating in the United States and
Canada before issuing his landmark
report to the Carnegie Foundation in
1910 the reflection report it was really
an expose of the shortcomings of
American medical schools across the
board in the decade after that half of
the medical medical schools the United
States simply shut their doors
the only two medical schools in New
England that were deemed worthy were
Yale and Harvard Flexner favored
University affiliated schools like the
one at Johns Hopkins in Baltimore that
would commit to both teaching and
research especially those with large
endowments or at least the potential to
raise funds to improve their research
facilities
once the Flexner report came out the
tide of philanthropy shifted to
education largely medical education but
general education as well the
Rockefellers gave flex fifty million
dollars to distribute that really woke
Yale up woke alumni up and the
Rockefeller Foundation said to Yale and
to other universities that were being
saved you can have our money basically
on three terms first your faculty have
to be on full-time employment as
professors of Medicine not with a
private practice second you have to have
access to the clinical material which
means patients and then third you've got
to match our money to assure greater
access to patients a more formal
agreement was reached in 1913 between
Yale University and the New Haven
Hospital
Connecticut's first teaching hospital
was now established during the first
decades of the 20th century American
medicine had undergone a major
transformation Medical Licensing was now
required to become a physician hospitals
were not only for the sick poor but also
for the community at large and for
medical education
and research had become central to the
enterprise now on a much firmer footing
the Yale School of Medicine was poised
for a sustained period of growth and
innovation propelled by two world wars
and a corresponding expansion of
research on the treatment of battlefield
injuries infections and other diseases
American medicine began to address the
demands of a modern world Yale School of
Medicine produced landmark medical
innovations during this time innovation
in medicine finds its way first to
academic medical centers where the
innovation is developed studied
experimented upon refined and improved
innovations that Yale School of Medicine
has been responsible for over the years
include the development of chemotherapy
the first use of penicillin the
development of technology in the
neonatal ICU environment
in 1911 child development pioneer Arnold
Cassell founded what would become the
Yale Child Study Center the Medical
School received its first federal grant
in 1919 a turning point in its
development as an engine for research
innovations in medical education were
also coming beginning with the hiring of
a new dean Milton Seawind Ternes then in
1920 another milestone Yale Corporation
included at the winter Nets who was has
been described as a steam engine in
pants so as dean winter nets really
oversaw profound changes at the medical
school
changes to the physical plan changes to
the faculty changes to the curriculum
one of the important changes to the
curriculum that he developed was what
became known as the Yale system and it
provided three really important things
one was a flexible
cohesive and collaborative learning
environment too was the mentorship that
they received from our faculty and the
third is the thesis I definitely chose
to come to you for the Yale system which
has been as remarkable as it was
advertised it gives us the flexibility
to really work with our classmates
and to interact with professors and not
be so concerned about numerical grade
the key to medical education today is to
teach your students to be self learners
they must be able to read the literature
critically judge the literature
determine what has changed and what's
true and whether they should modify
their practice accordingly a student
research day is the culmination of the
students participation in their thesis
so the thesis doesn't any important
things it has our students participate
directly in scientific discovery and in
learning things that will advance the
practice of medicine in order to do
their thesis our students work very
closely with the faculty mentor and this
close working relationship becomes so
important to our students I worked with
dr. Edison his a world expert in
cutaneous t-cell lymphoma and what never
ceases to amaze me is the amount of time
that he's willing to spend with medical
students one of the things that was
special about the patients that we
identified with these mutations is the
fact that they don't seem to be
responding to photo freezes and systemic
therapies in addition to educating
medical students the school graduates
dozens of PhD students each year in the
biomedical sciences along with public
health professionals physician
associates Hospital residents and
research fellows the medical library
houses one of the country's finest
historical collections including
pioneering neurosurgeon Harvey Cushing's
unique collection of clinical specimens
drawings and photographs the medical
librarians collection is considered
really one of the best in the world
throughout the 20th century the school
developed into a major center for
research in the biomedical sciences it
also took advantage of its close
proximity to the main Yale campus
located just a few blocks away and home
to many of the world's leading scholars
in the humanities for more than two
decades the humanities and medicine
program has connected medical students
and scholars with writers artists
historians and others with a unique
perspective relevant to medicine and the
human experience of illness
so this is how the Celia's started
really was with these sheets which were
prepared for teaching the importance of
humanities in medical school cannot be
emphasized enough with the things that
you see on the ward and the emotions
that that you experience the humanities
is definitely a place a venue that we've
used to sort of cultivate these these
emotions and express them in different
formats many students come here as well
trained musicians and so established now
two years ago is the Yale Medical
Symphony
by the 1960s a higher standard of living
and new public health measures meant
that Americans were living longer the
growing number of older citizens and the
introduction of Medicare in 1965 created
a much larger patient base a larger
demand for doctors and a sustained
period of expansion for medical schools
and teaching hospitals
Yale's medical school grew in this
period from a handful of departments to
more than two dozen today and from fewer
than 100 full-time faculty to more than
1,200 there are 28 departments here at
the Medical School about a third of them
are basic science departments that is
they do not participate in patient care
directly their role is to teach medical
students teach graduate students teach
postdoctoral fellows fundamental skills
of doing basic research they represent
fields including genetics cell biology
immuno biology physiology pharmacology
neurobiology and so on the other
two-thirds of departments are clinical
departments which have an extra mission
on top of teaching and research and that
is direct clinical care of patients the
close connection between bench and
bedside has led to major innovations in
clinical care at Yale over the decades
pharmacologists Alfred Gilman and Louis
Goodman were working during the 1940s
during wartime research on nitrogen
mustards which were poisoned gas
compounds essentially and what they
discovered was the killing action of the
nitrogen mustards actually worked to
shrink tumors in cancer patients their
search really marked the beginning of
cancer chemotherapy
Yale was designated one of the first
comprehensive cancer centers by the
National Cancer Institute in 1974
thirty-five years later in 2009 smile Oh
Cancer Hospital at Yale New Haven opened
is one of the most advanced clinical
centers for cancer care in the world
we're working hard to really create the
very best cancer hospital that we can a
cancer hospital which is innovative a
cancer hospital which is bringing new
treatments to patients children adults
patients who have a broad variety of
malignancies making sure they have
access to the very best care and the
very cutting edge research I think
innovation and medicine is an important
part of the practice of medicine I think
that that's what makes the Yale School
of Medicine unique there's a community
of scholars physicians of scholars are
trying to understand the most basic
mechanisms of disease and understand the
details about patients and to use that
information about patients to informs
the research and use advances from the
research to inform better patient care
and what we're trying to do is
understand what are the biomarkers or
one of the genetic markers that might
less predict one of the things about
Yale is yes has always been a place that
has had science at it's very heart
science plays an increasingly important
role in medicine medicine is a study of
biological phenomena going wrong so what
you see really is that scientific
discovery leads to technologic
innovation and application to medicine
itself a 20th century example of science
applied to medicine can be found in the
work of Dorothy Horseman at Yale Dorothy
wordsman solved one of the key problems
that had confounded scientists working
on polio for decades and she basically
went back and took a look at an earlier
stage than anyone had before at the
blood of polio patients and realized
that the virus had infected the
bloodstream but it hadn't been
discovered before because everybody had
tested too late and the virus had
already been destroyed by the antibodies
in the person's bloodstream
building on the work of Horseman than
others the first polio vaccines were
developed at the disease that devastated
20,000 lives a year in the US alone
was virtually eradicated Yale is a
special place in that I think there's
more communication here across fields
both between the different fields of
basic science and between basic science
and people who are primarily involved in
the clinical practice of medicine other
seminal discoveries by Yale researchers
have led to the development of new drugs
and therapies the hiv/aids drugs Irit
was discovered by Yale pharmacologists a
Yale team developed and tested the first
insulin pump for diabetes Lyme disease
was identified by two yale physicians in
1975 the medical school has focused its
translational research efforts toward
better understanding transplant
rejection cardiovascular disease
neurodegenerative diseases such as
Alzheimer's and multiple sclerosis and
immune disorders Yale has played an
enormous role the innovations that have
happened in medicine over the past 50 to
100 years some of the fundamental
discoveries of understanding how genes
work at the may be field we took the
approach of using extreme outliers in
the population patients who have
extremely high or extremely low blood
pressure and using tools of the genome
project to try to understand the
specific causes of these disorders and
this has taken us from discovery to new
applications of existing pharmaceutical
agents to treat patients to new
recommendations from the Institute of
Medicine for the reduction of salt in
the diet of every American the biggest
issue in this family is whether we want
to go ahead and do the whole exome
sequence or not key milestones at the
Yale School of Medicine include
development of the first transgenic
Mouse and important discoveries related
to autism just
Tourette's syndrome and I pretension in
addition fundamental discoveries such as
the inner workings of cells and how
proteins fold into their unique
three-dimensional shapes were made at
Yale the Yale stem cell Center dedicated
to understanding the basic biology of
cells that give rise to every kind of
tissue in the body was created in 2006
well you know success breeds success in
the academic world so when you have a
great institution like the N School of
Medicine with a great history and a
great reputation embedded in a great
university that's regarded as one of the
tops in the world it really does help
them recruiting faculty and we expect
that every faculty member coming in
ought to be a leader in the world in
their field and we try to instill that
same enthusiasm and spirit in our
students I'm really interested in public
health issues so I really would hope
that some claim I figure to be sort of
working in the department of health of
some sort even with the WHL or with the
CDC or at the NIH and one of the great
things about working in a university is
working with young people that's one of
the things I've really had most probably
most pleasure from last year in the
United States there were over 50,000
applicants to medical schools we had
over 4,000 applications we did eight
hundred interviews and from those eight
hundred applicants we selected our
hundred medical students so our class
size is a hundred and I think that
really fosters a collegiality in our
community we learn from each other and
we push each other forward most students
at the School of Medicine volunteer a
portion of their time to community
activities teaching human anatomy to
local high school students working in
the downtown evening soup kitchen or
providing care under the supervision of
faculty physicians in the student
organized
Haven free clinic and Wednesday evening
clinic students put out a literary
magazine perform with the Yale med
players theater group and in the second
year put on a highly entertaining if
somewhat irreverent review both
celebrating and mocking their favorite
professors and fellow students we have
great students sitting out may have an
Independent Spirit and they are
passionate about their careers our
students want to make a difference in
the world they want to contribute to the
future of Medicine in some important and
meaningful way excellent students
require exemplary teachers and Yale
School of Medicine's faculty are well
represented within the National Academy
of Sciences the Institute of Medicine
and the Howard Hughes Medical Institute
and they've been recognized
internationally with scores of prizes
and awards including the Nobel Prize the
ailich School of Medicine has set an
extraordinary level of excellence among
its faculty now their work is I think
sets a standard that everyone aspires to
and people have tremendous respect and
admiration for the really great leading
scientists and literally have dozens of
such people here at the Yale School of
Medicine it's a striking assembly of
talent that's a beautiful result because
it deals with that paradox that you've
got one receptor giving two possible
outcomes this department has been
responsible for quite some interesting
discoveries the discovery of how the
innate immune system works has been one
of the triumphs of the last decade or
two and it really started here we were
at the leading edge of using genetics to
unravel complex genetic traits such as
high blood pressure we were the first
University in the world to succeed in
doing genome-wide analysis of relating
common variants to a common disease with
macular degeneration we were the first
University in the world to sequence all
of the genes in the genome
in order to make a clinical diagnosis
the Yale Center for genome analysis is
one of the advanced core facilities
making state-of-the-art scientific
instrumentation available to faculty and
students across the university other
core facilities provide tools for RNA
interference molecular and cellular
imaging small molecule screening and
other cutting-edge technologies I think
the biggest transformation we're going
to see in the cancer area is this
concept of molecular profiling so that
patients when they come through the door
of smile will have a sample of their
tumor taken and we will then look for
all the genetic abnormalities that may
be present the acquisition of our new
West Campus in west haven connecticut to
seven miles from the main campus is
given us an opportunity to build
interdisciplinary collaborative research
programs at the cutting edge divorced
from the ordinary ordering of academic
departments and instead focused on
important themed attic areas of science
that will be very valuable in the future
further from home Yale School of
Medicine's international partnerships
with Fudan University in China
Macaroni University in Uganda and many
others will extend the knowledge gained
by Yale scientists to benefit patients
around the world Medical School faculty
have collaborations all over at major
one in London with the University
College London Medical Centre but there
are in the developing world great many
collaborations going ons we have people
doing medical research essentially on
every continent in collaboration with
scholars and investigators in addition
to that because we bring so many people
from all over the world here train them
and then send them out to University
positions all over the world we have
true global reach in the impact of the
work that we do
as Yale School of Medicine begins its
third century it seeks to educate the
future leaders of American medicine
while applying cutting-edge scientific
research to the goal of making people
healthier this is one of the most
exciting times to be a medicine for many
many viewpoints we will be able to be
much more specific in our diagnosis and
treatment and the benefit to individual
patients will be they will have
treatments that are tailored to their
specific inherited abnormalities they
will have early diagnosis of inherited
predisposition that will enable them to
either change lifestyle or change
therapeutics that in ways that will give
them better therapeutic outcomes because
we anticipate there will be new
medicines that will be more selective of
greater efficacy and reduced
side-effects probably the biggest impact
will have on the future will be through
the students that we educate they will
be the scholars and leaders of tomorrow
and they will be a part of the
transformation of medicine in the future
in addition our researchers will
continuously redefine the cutting edge
of science and our clinicians will
practice at the cutting edge and do the
clinical research that defines future
trends in clinical medicine the number
of resources available to us is nearly
unlimited anything that we can put our
minds to we can create here and it's
just such a fascinating and wonderful
place to be able to have these
opportunities available to us
you
you